welcome to this video playing am cetera
satara whatever they hung throw
Needleman that's pretty young players on
it icare behind me okay I always thought
you must play night ft 7 here but I'm
just a piece up here I cannot believe
what's going on here this is an IM
chennai probably still will lose the
game because I'm such yeah I'm such a
catch shape yeah check okay so how do i
play this i came from tonight him so
he's got he's got three pawns so it's
not like immediately hopeless or
anything okay maybe here keep their keep
them keep castling prevented if he takes
rook takes i really have a much better
development
rooks III I could have taken a castle
maybe nothing great but I really i have
overlooked this i am bid I admit it
totally unnecessary really what did I
give this up and I was getting really
far too many parts in man
yeah very tough to play in addition I
mean I have no points left almost no
pawns
what a game Bishop December this kind of
beginners mistake winning a piece and
the hand blender opens here okay so I
need need to drop retreat your first
check okay he might play Queen before
him getting getting the Queen's off
ablex position is very compact he's got
five points for the piece
check at least his pawn structure
slightly compromised
yeah mine as well but it always was what
what Lulu that's left of it
now maybe I can somehow get both
queenside porns but it looks it looks
difficult difficult to do we're up to
five or something
maybe if I get in route e5 but he's
playing it other time on the way
yeah I have no real way to to activate
my pieces that's the biggest problem I
mean no the biggest problem is the
material but
oh no this just this wasn't my lip but
I'm lost anyway so quite resigned Jaron
this is tougher I mean this is really
beginner's mistake with 57 I can only
call it like that after you five
blankets losing almost well he can do
the piece like it did in the game or
return to g8 okay this is just losing a
piece for four not much check but cat
what the heck did I show him what what
did I do wrong the problem is really I
just overlooked that this hangs on g2 I
mean this is for example this is just
keyboard the the big difference is I
still have some points here oops not
them I go here now this is this is very
nice for white as I have the activity
and he has some he does not really have
a good coordination him it just plus one
according to stock fish though maybe
it's in fact better check here to play
King f29 f3 and then Bishop to see 3
yeah this is maybe better that's better
for white quite clearly better but hard
to evaluate but assembly I simply forgot
that G to Hanks I mean this was just a
huge mistake giving away two points for
for nothing lamb just very bad very bad
and there was really no no way back
after that check this is the lost end
game and it was hard to keep Queens on
the bone marrow king is bad so
okay thanks for watching